forget that you might ever have done
anything wrong yourself take things
personally that computer broke down to
be money constantly compare your
existence with that of the happiest most
fortunate people you know expect that
there cannot ever be traffic and that
household keys simply can't go missing
buildup isolated frustrations into giant
interconnected narratives of persecution
become very sensitive to noise then move
to a city where a lot of people are
taking advantage of rising property
prices to redo their homes start to
notice fingerprints on walls chipped
plates and towels on bathroom floors CVS
has personal insults be sure not to get
enough sleep but never attribute your
moods to tiredness it's not children to
be grateful compare your relationship to
the happiest couple that the media is
choosing to tell us about at the moment
attribute most issues in your life to
the mendacity and shortsightedness of
your partner and their family avoid
perspective never look at NASA images of
distant galaxies find a YouTube channel
or news outlet that you're almost
certain to dislike watch some videos and
read articles and feel very irritated by
the presentation of views you strongly
disagree with never watch others getting
angry fail to see how absurd they can
see develop a faith that Fury is in some
ways quite impressive macho and make
stuff happen take yourself seriously and
yet deep down hate who you are think of
laughter as a luxury you can't afford
you
you